is men with a certain mindset have a
hard time being victims he did not say
that men can't be victim he did
obviously next to him he said do you
know what you said that you feel like
you're saying you said that you'll sit
in the room too of a woman that you feel
like should have yeah yeah not like my
view but the thing is sorry I just feel
like you're very like
you're like narrow-minded about
everything no at all you don't you don't
know me
of course but we're talking about this
as a discussion so you see him in
everyday life I'm completely different
but we're here to talk about this so of
course I'm gonna have a sister called
basically you feel you feel like the
sister code was broken
I can't believe I'm in here with two
women that uh that you know that
wouldn't because what it is I said a lot
of the time women believe that because
you're another woman you're supposed to
see it just the way I see it whereas
whereas whereas us as men you saw I
don't know why you saw these all of us
can disagree we don't necessarily think
that you're not believing us you're
saying you're blind too I understand but
at the same time that I was looking into
this too I feel like you're blind to it
yeah that's fine but that's our opinions
I've never met her in my life never no
we have the same opinion and so did you
react to a story is that how you're here
is that is did she was yeah I said yeah
well there you are so that would make
sense why why you agree with her and and
I don't agree with both of you really
because I have a lot of people on my
look at my comment section there's a lot
of people that disagree yeah but but
that's the thing that's what I'm saying
like you don't know me I'm not someone
to be online but my online my point my
point okay okay but my point is we're
two different women and every time we
talk about our beliefs on things you
discount it the feminist who who seems
to think we should believe women but
every time you say every time we say we
believe something you give an excuse me
no no you you say oh it's because you're
young oh it's because you're white oh
it's because that like like you give an
excuse for why we believe it instead of
just but the thing is we're just
different I said to you earlier though
I've seen some of the videos that and
when you've spoke about her certain
things the first thing is fat fat fat
people people are different I am
completely aware that means no no first
thing I do I do 16 hours of shows a week
and the first thing I say in every show
is fat no I'm talking about when you're
talking about women you like do you like
to describe them you like to to talk
about that and and whatnot but but what
I'm saying the teachers I I can
appreciate that you have got a different
opinion to me I knew I was coming on
here I knew I weren't going to agree
with you I knew that okay I'm pretty
sure that's why he said come on here
because he knew this yeah but at the
same time I I can accept that my my
circumstances my my life has gone in a
completely different direction and we
will never agree so into a sense I'm not
saying I'm not saying that what you're
saying is [__] I'm not saying that you
are who you are because you're young
I'll just be interested to see how you
would feel about certain things
I know I'm young but I feel like
as young as I may be I could have I
could be free so much yeah yeah I mean
and that's the thing you don't know my
story yeah that's what I'm trying to say
is as much as I've been free so much I
don't have the same of course but if I'm
gonna listen to the 20 year old or I'm
gonna listen to the 74 year old that's
had a life of experience a 74 year old
somebody listened to see that's what I'm
saying to you like no no I talk to a lot
of people you you don't really like you
don't know I talk to her a lot I would
say I would argue I talk to more people
I I would agree I would agree
I think for me it's your inability to
understand that your your experiences or
the things you because in my experience
people like you tend to chase certain
narratives because it's like what you
want to hear you want to read something
you want to reaffirm the idea that
everyone is experiencing these kinds of
um these these confirmation bias when
you look at when you look at the data
and it says oh 100 people experience uh
you know that essay in in London and you
realize that like 150 000 people died
from cancer and almost 400 000 people
died from everything else you discount
all that all those other causes of
mortality all those issues and say oh
but a hundred people died in one year
and that's a sign that don't you believe
there's a massive issue
100.
this is what makes me laugh about these
sort of discussions
what do you think every man's like we're
just talking about sit there I never
ever
smaller numbers the right words
sometimes sometimes you're using rare
occasions to justify one second
can I can I just read something so
um just going off of the great thing I
this is a U.S stat I will say not UK
um from 1995 to 2010 the estimated
annual array of female grape or sa
victimization declined from declined 58
from five victimizations per a thousand
females
um to 2.1 per thousand so it's not but
isn't it
how do you know well I see that I'll
find that what do you mean it's less
supported the thing is okay let's just
take that premise okay like so that
that's that's your argument that there's
more grape and it's not reported how
would you know how would you know it
doesn't happen I assume every man is a
predator
so don't flip the question on me yeah
sorry so I know people I know numerous
people that have been raped and having
fun yeah
let me just get this straight so you're
going off of Word of Mouth no personal
experience who I know so so okay okay
people you know yeah how did you know
were you there
it sounds like this this is a sort of
woman diet not offends to you that you
look at me and think [__] that I look at
you and think [__] that like I don't
know the question
answer the question I know I wasn't
there sorry I wasn't there I wasn't
there so it's based off of what what
they've it's based off of what they said
correct
so your that means you're discounting
anyone and this is convictions
answer my question is it was I there are
you are you basing this opinion off of
what women say
um it's it's more sort of how I see no
not emotion how I see the situation if I
know someone
uh say if I know someone had never had
sex before in their life and wasn't that
way inclined and then got great I would
believe them because from what I've seen
from them they're not like that okay but
it's based off of what women say but but
how would you not believe it yeah of
course of course but who would would you
in that situation
you keep flipping that no I'm asking you
whatever I'm saying exactly
yes
so so so I'm just I'm just clarifying so
so your assertion that that it's
underreported is based off of believing
women without evidence 100 okay that's
that's my only point so so then so then
so if you follow the logic what can we
do in society
or how do you think society would run if
we believed everybody about wait just
wait if we believed everybody
based on what they said without any
evidence well I I think that's bollocks
but we're not talking about that we're
not talking about everything that'd be
like you saying oh that sound bloke was
racist to me and I say prove it yes
that's exactly what it is that this is
the theme because are you now just
supposed to I feel like this because I'm
just supposed to take what I say
happened or should there be evidence to
also back it up I I completely
understand what you're saying and I
agree I agree it would be a dangerous
world if we could if we could just
believe everything do you see what I
mean please please but please but you're
not you're not getting it but I'm
looking at a bigger picture so I say if
you said to me
um I'll start someone's racist or
whatnot I I can appreciate we live in a
slightly racist country so I would kind
of uh as you use my brain and think you
know what because at the end of the day
there's not evidence for everything so
you you're you're kind of as much as as
you're that kind of saying to me I
believe in everyone
um
it's a bit dangerous as well the flip
side to to only credit people with
evidence because evidence there's
there's you can you can watch stuff like
this and you can see whether it's murder
or what and it'll be discounting all
evidence
these random little things to brew my
pain what you just said is absolutely
not saying this but just saying I could
go to someone and say he was racist too
yeah of course you could and because
you're white yeah someone should believe
me no I'm not I'm not saying about this
again this is where it gets twisted I'm
saying from my own personal view I know
people but I know that people have been
great and they haven't reported it so
when it comes to Great statistics in the
same way like we talk about men's
problems and whatnot that male suicide
we know is is higher but women women
commit
more they tried to commit more and they
report it more so if men reported it
more maybe it would be a case of women
trying more do you see what I mean but
in this year if you're not reporting
things but at the same time you can view
male suicide as extremely sad you're
like you're moving the goal post because
you're not listening to a word so she
made a point no no no you keep doing it
no it's not because I think every time
someone brings up a point yeah
I'm saying I could literally come out
here today and say of course you're like
you could I could literally cry okay go
cry to someone say you was racist but
the thing is if someone if someone
believes I don't believe her don't
believe her because you're white that's
fine I will stand there and I know I've
got people that know me that will back
me and say that I have it fair enough
they weren't there a man could say that
someone I could say you know what I
believe that he's not yeah of course I
know her she's not I know the truth
she's not alone I've known her for 10
years but she knows she's lied but she
knows she's lied about it
no but this but then but again you're
kind of not because I'm saying this is
where those sort of viewpoints come from
Injustice no no but do you understand we
understand how bad it is and that's why
men can just be pinpoint as they've done
how many men that this is the thing
there's people on telly that have been
accused of a rape there's been there's
been people on telly that have been
accused of it there's been there's been
footballers and this whole rhetorical oh
you're doing it again no because this
whole rhetorical it ruins men's lives
it's hard to believe when you're seeing
men go off living living Prof like
profitable lives after that's happened
to them where they were were they were
they prosecuted or were they accused
they were they were accused but this is
what I'm saying okay but see there there
you go again if you've never got the
evidence because it's my word against
theirs okay but yeah this is just this
is just this is just what we're going
back to you just believe women without
evidence and that's and I and these are
I would rather believe a woman and then
and then listen listen and in this case
in this case you don't even know them
yeah yeah so you can't even make the
argument the case you just made where
you said there are footballers that have
that have gotten away with it you're
believing women you don't even know I
all believe in a man not to be a great
person you don't know no we're not
believed no no no stop putting words
into my mouth that I did not say I did
not because I was saying so you're
neutral to the situation
I I said to believe the evidence so to
wait until the evidence comes out and if
and if there's no evidence then I would
decide on the fact that it probably
didn't happen or there was not enough
evidence to prosecute I don't or there
was not enough evidence to prosecute but
I don't know I was not there why would I
make an assumption on something that I
was not there for that that's fine not
you but this is what I'm saying that
if you want to believe that that's
that's fine I I personally don't believe
that and I understand when it comes to
this there's such a fine line because
how are you getting that evidence bear
in mind there was uh that there was a
thing up until because is that no can I
just say something that if I was if I
was brutally graped and you started and
I went to the police and then you
started digging into my sexual history
and found out that I liked being I liked
rough sex that goes against me but yet
that was consensual so even that that
that rule has only changed recently that
would make sense but no it doesn't
because it doesn't yeah if someone has
an Evidence of certain Behavior patterns
yeah so I see but again like this is
what I'm saying we just we just believe
different things and that's fine and and
why why would you want them to be able
to prosecute someone without evidence
because certain things never have any
evidence okay so that's really so you
think they should process
I see what you're saying but if it meant
like how are you gonna how are you gonna
tell me now then if I if a man doesn't
inside me or there's no DNA or say there
is DNA but there's no much tell tell me
what evidence you would need to believe
it
typically typically if you you're
fighting yeah if you're getting engraved
so typically I would imagine there's
Cuts there's there's there's like like
bruises that sort of thing but do you
know why do I not I I don't because I'm
not there and I don't make assumptions
based off of gender I don't I don't
believe people can I use an analogy
right well you're because you're saying
basically you believe we're women right
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait that's what you said
you basically are saying be a believer
woman right and as a and and I tell you
what a scary for me as a as a black male
yeah yeah it's no hang on I'm just gonna
say I'm scared for me as a black male
because I don't know if you know the
case of Emmett Till yeah of course right
okay where a woman said that he yeah
right and they were living at a time
sorry essayed
um to some degree or even wolf whistled
or whatever it was right and because she
was a woman and like you say oh she was
a white woman she was believed right and
that boy I know brutally because of her
yeah now you're telling me right
generally believable women as if women
can't lie so like I'm saying I'm looking
at it the standpoint you're looking at
it from is a woman's standpoint I'm
looking at it from a man's standpoint
yeah like I said if men get accused of
something yeah it can ruin our whole
life and this is why Pearl is talking
about it has to be evidenced based it
does it's not saying that you that it
never happened that's not no one's
saying that it never happened I think
that's I think I think no but listen but
listen No but listen no one's saying it
never happened we're saying if it did
happen there has to be some kind of
proof that it actually did happen but
this and if it didn't
there's cases where there is evidence
and it still gets discounted I this is
what I'm saying this is what I'm going
back to no no no it's not but then I'll
go back to what I said to you the bottom
line is I would rather believe a liar
than a rapist and and then that's it
that's it I rather believe it a lot I
I'm not a Believer like I would rather
wake up one morning and find out the
person I believe like
is is capable of that as opposed to a
man capable right I think that's easier
to say when you're not the one in their
shoes
so this women will assassinate a man's
character and spread lies about him
because women can be spiteful a hundred
percent
and so I personally I'm not just gonna
give women that power to destroy a man's
character reputation right job
opportunities College opportunities just
because a woman is a woman that's stupid
yeah she felt a certain way but at the
same time it makes me sad to think of oh
um the the women out there that didn't
have the evidence that didn't they got
for an alcohol that we can look at
statistics in in sort of that cool and
how much it goes against them yeah of
course but that's for that it's not no
but then I don't want to like go in
there do you do you think it's better to
be innocent until proven guilty or
guilty till proven innocent it is that's
a tough one because I think I think
money and power pick one has no that's
what I'm saying I can't yeah you can't
have a perfect world pick one no no no I
I I don't know how to answer that
because what's fairer what's fairer
what's what's more fair well of course
the the fairer were of the two is um
with with evidence of course that no no
you mean innocent until proven yeah
that's what I'm saying that's the third
but this is why I don't want to answer
this question because even though I can
see it so do you want to live in a fair
Society or on earth oh [__] you're
you're doing this again when you're kind
of like throwing questions at me you're
not really listening to kind of what I
was trying to get out right we've been
listening no no but I'm saying I'm not I
would I don't want to pick one or two
because I don't agree with either
because I think disprove your point no
no it's because if you've got money and
you've got power you can get up with
everything you ever need to be right if
you've got money and you've got a power
if you've got money and power you can
get away with everything if you have
money and power you get away with
everything a lot there's like there's
this there's a chef that's got a
restaurant in London and Parks outside
there every day even though there's no
parking Zone and he just gets a ticket
every day because he can get away with
it because he's got money we okay I
think there's a difference between
tickets
then why is R Kelly in jail how long did
that take I was in school when that sex
tape came out with him graping with him
doing whatever he'd done to that okay
okay what happened at the end how long
did it take what happened
how many how many women I don't know how
many women weren't believed what
happened at the end of the day how long
did he go to jail how long did he go to
yeah of course yeah you know he went to
jail we all know that but how long did
that take how many that video that video
I went to call and it got it got thrown
out okay okay is he in jail now
yes how many women did he hurt after
that first because because it's innocent
until proven guilty he had the video
innocent because it's innocent did
anyone know that I I don't I don't I
don't know I'm telling you this I know
I'm telling you I don't know but I'm
saying at the end of the day is he not
in jail because if if you said he could
your your claim your claim was that he
could get that people with money in
power can go yeah
okay where are they now how long did it
take sometimes just why do you keep
answering questions what's the point
whether it's relevant or not that they
got they got done
how often how often do people go
discredited if you watch those documents
you have a need to be right you watch
those documentaries there was countless
women not believe because there weren't
anymore
I don't feel like you're lit you're
trying to listen it doesn't surprise me
that it's coming from this I I've had
this numerous times and fair enough that
yeah I I know I can I can talk loud and
I can be outspoken but I know full well
that what I'm saying is not is true but
it's true to me but you don't need you
don't know me at all that this is what I
was saying I weren't ever looking at you
when I said to you earlier about that
predator and what not that I've got
respect for men I have however just in
terms of like the world view and that
when we talk about how they built this
world because we should be we should be
thankful I I don't look at that I don't
think it's a nice place
yeah because you don't have a respect
for men
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible